BARTON ZWIEBACH: Now
that we've introduce h,
h is a very important
quantity in quantum mechanics.
So let's talk a little
more about h, its units,
and we already put one
number that I really
wish you will remember.
Now let's talk
about the units of h
and some other things
you can do with h.
So units of h.
So if you have a quantity that
appears for the first time
and as it appears
here, E equal h nu,
this is a good place to
understand the units of h
because the units of h
would be units of energy
divided by units of frequency.
And I put this square
brackets to denote units.
Now what are the
units of energy?
We're going to work with
units that are characterized
by M, L and T--
mass, length, and time.
So energy, you think kinetic
energy and you say, MV squared,
so that's a mass
and velocity squared
is L squared over T squared.
So that's units of energy.
Frequency is cycles
per unit time.
Cycles have a number of units,
so it's 1 over time here.
So then you say that
it's ML squared over T.
So that's the first
answer and that's
a nice answer,
although it's never
quite that useful in this way,
so we try to rearrange it.
And I will rearrange it the
following way to think--
you see, it's nice to think of
what physical quantity that we
are familiar, hats
units of h-bar.
We know these units of h-bar
are energy over frequency,
but that's not a single physical
quantity, so let's look at it
and separate this as L times
MLT. That's the same thing.
And then I see an
interesting thing--
this is the units of
position, or length.
Length or radius.
Distance.
And this has the
units of momentum p.
Momentum.
So this product has the
units of angular momentum.
And perhaps that's the
most important quantity
that has the units of h-bar.
It's something that
you should remember.
Of h-bar has units
of angular momentum,
that's why when people talk
about a particle of spin 1/2,
they say the angular
momentum is 1/2 of h-bar,
and that has the right units.
So spin 1/2 particle--
1/2 particle-- means
that the magnitude
of the intrinsic angular
momentum is 1/2 of h-bar.
h or h-bar have the same units,
they just differ by a 2 pi
that--
unfortunately, we have to
be careful about that 2 pi,
it affects numbers
and some formulas
are nicer without the bar,
some formulas are less nice.
So OK.
So another thing
that you could say
is that this h allows
you to construct
all kinds of new quantities.
And that's a nice thing to do.
Whenever you have a new constant
of nature that comes up,
and we have the speed of
light, Planck's constant,
Newton's constant-- seem to
be the three fundamental units
of nature--
you can do some things.
And you can look
at this quantity--
h is proportional to rp
and get an inspiration.
So you can think h has
units of r times p.
And you can say, look--
if I have any
particle with mass M,
I can now associate
a length to it.
I can invent a length
associated to that particle.
And how do I do it?
Well, this has units of
length, so all I have to do
is take h and divide by p.
Well, that will be one
way to get the length
where p is the momentum, and it
will be called the de Broglie
wavelength.
But there is another way.
Suppose this particle
is just not moving
and you have the momentum
and you say, wow,
momentum is not moving,
so what's going on here?
So think of it at
rest and then you say,
well, you still can
construct a length.
You can put h and divide by
the mass times the velocity
of light, why not?
That's a velocity, it
is a constant of nature.
So that way, you
associate a length
to any particle of a given mass.
You don't have to tell
me what is the momentum.
You can just know
the mass and it
has a length associated to it.
So it's called the Compton--
Compton-- wavelength
of a particle.
And I want to make
sure you don't confuse,
it's not the same as
de Broglie wavelength
that we will see later.
It's not the same as the
de Broglie wavelength.
This is the Compton
wavelength of the particle.
And you can say,
all right, good,
you give me a
particle of some mass,
I can tell you what a
length associated to it--
why would it be important?
It will be important
in two different ways--
through an experiment and
through a thought experiment,
which I want to do right now.
You see, I could ask
the following question--
I have this particle, has a mass
M. I use the speed of light,
so with that mass M, I could
associate out to this particle
a rest energy.
MC squared.
That's the rest energy.
And then I could ask,
what is the wavelength
of a photon that has the
same energy as the rest
energy of this particle?
So you translate the question
into a question of a length.
Once you have some energy,
there is a natural length,
which is the wavelength of
a photon with that energy.
So let's ask this question
independently of what we did.
So what is the wavelength--
wavelength-- of a photon whose
energy is the rest mass--
rest mass-- of a particle?
So the rest mass is
MC squared, and that's
the energy of this photon.
And we know that energy of a
photon h nu or hC over lambda,
and there, we can
calculate the lambda.
Lambda is hC over MC
squared, and no surprise,
it gives us h over
MC and that thing
is the Compton wavelength.
So it's sometimes
called l-Compton
of the particle of mass M.
So this is a way that you
can think of this particle.
You think of a particle, you
have a Compton wavelength,
and that Compton wavelength
is the wavelength of light
that has that rest energy.
And that actually has
experimental implications
in high energy particle physics.
Because if you have an
electron and it has a Compton
wavelength, and you shine a
photon that has that size,
that photon is
carrying as much energy
as the rest energy
of the electron.
And in particle theory
and quantum field theory,
particles can be created and
destroyed, so this photon maybe
can do some things and
create more particles out
of this electron, particle
equation could start.
happening.
So it will be difficult to
isolate a particle to a size
smaller than its
Compton wavelength,
because the photons could do
such damage to the particle
by creating new particles
or doing other things to it.
So for an electron, let's
calculate the Compton
wavelength.
So l-Compton of an electron
would be h over MeC,
and you would do h--
you would do 2 pi h-bar
C over and MeC squared.
And you've got 2 pi
197.33 MeV fermi,
and here you would
have 0.511 MeV.
So this gives you 2,426 fermi,
or about 2.426 picometers.
Picometers is kind
of a natural length.
Picometer is 10 to
the minus 12 meters.
The Bohr radius is
about 50 picometers,
so that's how big this thing is.
Is it still much bigger than
the size of the nucleus?
The nucleus is a few fermis.
A single proton is
about a fermi big.
And nucleus grow
slowly, so you can
have a big nucleus with
200 particles maybe
of a radius of 7 or 8 fermi.
So this is still a
lot bigger and it's
a very interesting quantity
that will show up very soon.